want to talk about just in the history
of the show
some of your favorite moments in the
history of drag race so my favorite
moments are watching the girls the
contestants break through their limited
perception of themselves it's almost
like watching a rebirth and we've seen
it with so many they come here and they
think wow I'm not funny
well Trinity Bonet just tore it up in a
comedy yes and you got to watch her
evolve into something she didn't even
know she was I know she was that but to
convince someone else that you are
bigger than you think you are is is huge
you have changed my life forever
do you have a favorite challenge out of
all the ones well I always loved the
snatch game because that's the
make-or-break challenge for the girls
because you get to see how quick they
are how imaginative they are and also
how they're able to get the essence of a
character that they choose to portray
some people fall hard in snatch game but
others really excel there's usually
always one surprising snatch game I
don't give a rat's ass because this game
is boring the [ __ ] out of me you have a
favorite lip sync for your life out of
all the years there've been many I loved
Roxxxy Andrews and Alissa Edward at wig
moment the wig feeling Oh taking off one
week to reveal another wig biosea those
gifts of you and Michelle visage will be
on the internet forever
and of all the guest judges is there a
judge that you really want to see on the
show I want Tyra Banks on this show
she would be great on the show uh my
dream the judge would be the real judge
of all judges Judge Judy oh my ultimate
get for this show well maybe next time
we talked to Judge Judy we'll let her
know yeah I think she knows I think
she's probably I think the restraining
order against me has let me know that
she knows I want her on this show did
you forget you were coming to court
today dressed like that